Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to a video where I play
some rage games.
Now you guys know I don't handle rage too well
but there was a game jam just recently where they focused explicitly
on games that made you angry.
So I'm gonna be playing a small snippet
from as many as I possibly can
and it all starts with a game called "Fish Out of Water"
which is a lot like "Getting Over It", I've heard.
Now these games aren't ALL like "Getting Over It",
but THIS one is about a fish,
and the fish jumps towards mouse.
(quietly) That's nice...
Oh that's real nice...
Oh that's- oh boy.
Okay?
Well how?? (chuckles)
(laughing) I've- I've fallen over and I can't get up!
How do-
Ooh, ah I can jump farther if-
(laughing) Oh
Hiyah!
The farther the mouse, the longer the jump.
Alright?
Oh boy this is still gonna be bad, ain't it?
Alright.
HOOO!!
Nope.
HEEHOO!!
(laughing) Oh come on, come on!
HeeHOO!!
Ha HA hah
WohOHOah
Okay,
Alright I can- I can do this-
Oh no I can't do this.
Hah- (laughs)
Oh
Did I go- oh! I went in- I-
Oh go in the sewer and you're good.
Ooh I get it.
Well they were kind enough to give me a tutorial
Which is- which is far better than I guess
Bennett Foddy talking to ya in your ear the whole time.
Oh this is delightful!
Oh no, this is not gonna be delightful.
(nervously laughs) Oh no
I have to wonder why this fish
decided to
go on this- wonderful adventure?
Oooh boy.
Haah
(laughing) Oh no
I'm stuck in the cr- oh no, the crevasse was good for me.
Ahahah..
Alright..
HUUUH!
nO!
Nnno!
NO!
WHERE?
WHY????
NOOO!
NOOOOoooo...
Where am I?!
Where am I???
Ooh- oh...
(Mark laugh/crying)
I'm 30 seconds- (puberty) 45 seconds in and I've already broken the game.
I'm sorry.
Hee hoo (Mark laughing)
Hee hOO
Ha ha ha
hee..
HOO HOOHOo.
Alright, this time I'ma t-
(inhale)
fUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUCK me. (miserable laughing)
What happens if I just keep going? Can I get out of here?
OH look I'm out, I'm free- Oh no
Oh this is no- oooh
nohohohoho...
(Mark bursts into laughter)
I just started!
I just started, I'm sorry, I just started!
I didn't mean to break it!
It's not my fault.
Eh, it's probably my fault.
Then again this was made in a game jam, so it's not gonna be like
a hundred percent polished.
But I'm gonna try to-
try to succeed at this wherever success may lie-
Oh (laughing) boy
Ohhhh BOY
Aha boy
Oh boy
Okay.
OH boy
Alright, I'm only assuming that I'm supposed to-
go this way. Let me slide my scaly body
LEAP!!
Ooh too far, TOO F- oh no
My boat!
You flipped mah boat!
I didn't even know I could do that!
Yeah.
Haiyah!
Huyuu.
No, no, no not into the void again..
AUGHHHH
Ahaha
Okay
Alright.
We got this. I can't go...
TOO far- No, I can't go to short either!
Oh frick.
I don't have enough chairs to break.
(laughs) This is only the first game in the series of games that I've had
Ooh
Y'know I- I hadn't heard of a rage game jam before but
it only seems logical at this point considering that-
Oh, shit dicks. Goddamn it!
Considering that they're simplistic enough to make-
That they're- I mean, game jams are home for big games and surgeon simulator
one of the- one of the- one of the rage games of yore.
How did I do this so easily before? I had this- oh
I had this so perfectly, uh, good god
I had this so perfectly done!
I-I had it so perfect! I was going THROUGH the map-
that's how good I was!
Oh, come on!!
Oh, you floppy fuck
(pained laughter) Oh no..
Okay
There we go! Alright, slide my scaly boooody
All right not, too far! Hooop- God fucking damn it!
Oh god, it was better when I was overconfident
Oh, it's impossible to judge distances here.
It's- ah- it- (chuckles)
It's impossible. At least it's not momentum based!
OoOoh (mumbles) might be momentum based-
Okay
NOOOOOOOOO
I DIDN'T KNOW I HAD TO JUMP RIGHT AWAYY!
Ohh, frick my dick. [Nah, I'm good.]
Oooh nOO...
C'mon fishy....
Come on fishy-wishy...
Come on! Ohh, go! No, don't go! Don't go! Go!
Oh don't go...
Ho boy
HO BOY
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, (screeches) NOOOO
God, fuck meehehehehe (pained laughter again) I hate it
Oh.... I hate it! I hate it!
At least this is better than a lot of the- the "Getting Over It" clones out there
Oh man, I mean, the mechanincs of this are new, so,
kinda qualifies as its own
I guess? Oh, God...
NOO!
Please...
NOOO, goddamn it!
NOOho!
How did I do this so confidently before?!
There please... There pl- noo
NOO!
Oh (pained laughter) god, no... NO!
I di- I was fine!
Ah fuck!
Okay, this is the position...
Get it distant- nope. Position, get it
There we go.
Get it.
Oh, come- WHYYYY?!!
FUckin' WHYY?!
WHY, WHY, WHY!! WHy...
Why?
There we go, up on the barrel.
Up on the rock-l
You go here...
You go a little over and up and there you go. Nice and easy.
Nice- come on
Hup!
Come on!
Come on!!
Fuck..
God, I had this so nicely before, this is so nice.
Good. Now, jump and then jump, but no jump, oh
Okay.
Let's nudge just a-
(small voice) nudge just a bit more...
EEYY!
Yes! Yahahaha!
(Mark, triumphantly, trying to laugh his way past this obviously hard part)
Okay, I gotta get up on that barrel.
OK, that's fine.
nooooo...
NonononoNONononono...
Yes, yes, yes and leap!
Yes! Okay, all right. We're doing good, we're doing good.
We're doing good, I can't believe we're doing good
Whoa..yes...aaahh.
Okay, huh. All right so far so goo... I don't know if anything's--
(quietly) gonna get in my way.
Am I supposed to go in that pipe?
Or over?
I'm gonna guess over. HUH!
Nailed it. HUH! Nope, didn't nail that.
HUH! Nailed it. All right I'm doing great! There's no way I'm gonna fail now.
Look at me now, ma.. mom.. mommy brea-- me.
Oh, oh.
Oh boy, precision. Ha, good thing I'm so fucking precise.
NOOO! NOOO! NAA!
(Markiboo channeling through)
I got this, huuh.
Noohohohohohoho...
AH!
I had it so good, what happened to me? I just- I could go through it the first
time and then I fuckle it all over the place. I can't help but fuckle it.
Why can't--?!
AHHHH!
It's like leaning a corner on its edge. How I'm able to--
EUUUUGH!
I was so perfect.
I was so perfect and now suddenly- oh I'm garbage!
I'm gar- well I'm IN a trash can!
So I guess-
being fucking garbage is fine!
NOOO!!
Oh you- (Mark sounds)
(Mark sobbing in pain)
EEEEE- NO!
NO!! NO!! NAAAW!!!
(pained chuckle)
Goddamn it.
(painfully) Haiyah...
Come on- OH there we go okay.
Made it (x3) you just gotta squiggle it! You gotta squiggle real good.
Heh, and I'm good at squigglin'.
I'm the best squiggler there ever was...
Oh i don't trust this at...
(loud sing song) AAAALL~
Good thing I don't trust anything
at...  (soft sing song) all~
(Mark sound)
No, no (small laugh) you wanted to s- uuuuh
What do I do here?
Oh no
Oh no, is that-?
Is- is- is this even-??
Ooooh pmhpmhpmhpmh (proceeds to cry)
(tearfully) I'm gonna fall!
I'm gonna fall!
I'm gonna- NOOO!!!
(Mark cries in agony)
Okay it's fine.
Oh boy.
Back in the trash heap where I belong.
God...
Help me..
Please...
(painfully) nooooo NO COME ON!!
Oh fucking...
(whines) My hops are so weak!
Don't, don't... please-
NOOO!! COME ON!! I spent so long!
Nudge Nudge Nudge Nudge Nudge Nudge
There. (mumbles) and...
Boink- Yes.
Okay just gotta nudge it, that's all it ever was
That's all my problem ever-?
This is all my problem ever was skip to my lou skip, to my lou skip, to my lou skip liske bow
Ok, skippity boom Bah skip better be boh! Buh! Bah! Boom, ok but beep bop boop beep ( apparently mark is a robot)
all right
it's the slightest of nudges here I go that's gonna be the jump to end all jumps eh? tip tippy toppy tip NONONONONOOOO!*Mark cries inside* COME ON
COME ON! Why you do Me like that?!
why would you do? I don't slippies slide off of here oh god OH GOD! *Mark Groans* Oh I hate it *Mark Cries*
Get on the fucking barrel no, not in the crevasse *Mark Regrets playing the game* This is Fucking Bullshit
No, I why did I try it again i've done that a million times it dosent work! *Mark Sobs and laughs*
I've lost it all again
Oh How quickly the brave have fallen no, no, okay
No, come on fucking i'll take the boat with me fuck you!
No....
did that no sound exactly like the no from getting over it just oh no.. that's all i have left in me i wish this fish could talk
NO fucking come on! *Mark Laughs in agony*
I'm not, even like dialing it in oh fuck come on NO Come on! I was- That had to be a big jump!
Come on why did I have to fall I didn't even get the opportunity to do what I wanted to do it slipped me off!
why did it slip me off *Mark groans hating every second of the game*
There we go oh, no no you can bounce you floppy fuck oh?
No, no! GOD FUCK How did I launch that far?!
Just, go just go just go Just GO JUST GOOOOAHHH
NOOO!, come on
Not done loved-up, i'm not done oh
Oh come on!
Ah!
come on
jesus just oh my god it's just the fucking barrel oh
My god don't go in the mountain i saw you trying to creep inside that mountain
you don't belong there you belong out here in hell with me fuck you okay what the fuck was that!
Come on there we go, please stay oh please please clap
Please i'm back in it to win it baby i'm back in i'm back in it to win it
BA-BY Im
why did that happen
I'm back in it to win it baby
baby
huh, alright we've made it to our quote unquote "safe zone" even though nothing is safe in this world
no one was safe and nothing is safe from
nobody haha made it back up there asshole you thought that you could-
NOOOO
*sigh* It's times like this I ask why I do this
To myself
nope alright well go right back down you know if anything I just don't like progress
That's just me as a person just got a scooch a looch it can't be in a hurry or else i'll get worry
i'm crying because both that wasn't a clever thing to say it god why am I rhyming okay back here just give me a
Chance to make the jump please that's all I ask just give me a chance to make the jump
That's fine
Okay just give me a chance give me a goddamn chance that's all I ask?
*softer* just gimmie a god damn chance
Okay here we go for this corner boink yes yes yes, no yes YASS
okay we're fine oh my god oh my god oh my god
Where do I go do I go that way I just spit on my monitor which way do I go
Why do I have a funny feeling I need to be down there but I don't want to flop down there or else it could end very-
I'm just gonna go for it- AH TOO FAR
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOoooooo
*extreme pain*
I
hate
you floppy fuck you floppy
fuck-you floppy fuck
come on I'm clicking I'm clicking I'm clicking why you no jumping??! I spit on my monitor again
there we go,
NOOOOOOOOOOO!!! *Mark Screams In pain*
FUCKING
every fucking time you floppy bouncy fuck
I Want to die I wanna die
I'm wanna die I wanna to die I want to die I want
To die stab me in the neck I want to die I want to die! (Nooo Mark you dont wanna die you are just saying that)
Put me in a coffin bury me underground I want to die I want to be dead
Everything i'm oh my god I want to die NOOOOOO I want to die I wanna die *noise of pain and inner suffering*
This is the point of the game where i got to turn my mic game down so i don't blow out everyone's fucking
Eardrums if the green ripper if the grim ripper could come and rip my goddamn soul out from under my  body
*laughs but in pain*
I made it but im crying
comes something but i'm crying
*sounds of crying* thats not good, thats not
a healthy sign *laugh*
The big bounce you think of bouncing out of bounds there were ya? you bouncy fuck or back here down oh?
Yeah, now i know we're back here now because every single time i land it happens to be on a knife's edge, oh?
You bouncy piece of shit...yet yep see look i'm standing up now
wUhuHUHUHU
No, no, no you fucking don't
No you fucking don't
Alright I made it I made it no are you guys gonna make it back
Why do we have to make it back we don't have to actually play this game
*mocking self* Whats that? I dont have to play this game??
OH! I didn't know that!
HUHUHUHUH,
*complete concentration*
Bing bong.
okay, no, nOOOOOO!!!!!
NO NO NOOOO!!!
my bing-bong did me wrong
NOOOOOO!!!!!!
*silence.... is he okay?* *I have no clue, I think he died inside*
*silent crying*
i'm not happy
I'm not- NOOOO COME ON!
*Laughs into saying Fuck* How???? *laughing/crying*
Ok, back on track in it to win it, i'm so ready like spongebob
*phone ding* Who the fuck? and go not, too far yes just like that that is the good stuff
Okay just a little more.... okay i'm not gonna go crazy
now, i'm just gonna go
perfectly sane not
Incredibly yes just like that baby just like that okay i'm in that but that's okay you know what i'm fine
with that
boink, yes!
Nailed that! i am good okay i'm good i'm good that's a hell of a jump?
that,,,, okay
I think i need to be up there because, no, even that would
Nope, that, don't be on your knifes oooookay. Oh boy okay
Ah nooo- ahahahaHAHA
HO HO HO OH HO HO HO
okay
Fuck that's, that's quite a leap I don't know if I can make that maybe I need to be up here too no, okay that's
okay I don't like it at all
No, I knew it I knew it I knew it no, no!!
FUCK YOU!! *crying*
Come on!!! you can't even recover! *sighs*
*P A I N*
No, why do I keep trying that? why do I think that'll work? what part of my brain just forgets? Oh my god
Oh my god..
Oh my *laughing* God
GOD
STOP!! JUST STOoOoP!!!
OH MY GOD!!!
*painful sigh* Ok, I made it.
YAY
*gibberish*
*insert crying markiplier meme*
*Screams of horror*
Uh! Fuckin- why can't I do this simple-
OH MY GOOOOOD!
JUST GET ON THE FUCKING BARREL
no fucking what the fuck? are you instant jump THEN?
Oh my GO-hahaD
Oh my Go-hahad
No, no, no, no no god i was fine! i was fine! i was fine!
Oh, i was fine i was fine
Everything was fine for okay
alright oh my god no oh
jesus pleeese
Oh, I can't do it
ohhAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHH
i'm just getting flustered that's all i am that's all this is god stop sitting on your edge
Okay, i'm back in it to win it a-fucking-gain don't fuck me
it's all i aaaAASSSK
it's all i asked
literally i'm not asking for much of anything i'm just asking you to give me a ch- *Gasp*
Didn't trust it i didn't trust it i didn't trust it and for good reason
okay, no god fucking damnit fuck (Why hasn't he stopped he is gonna go crazy and this is the first game!)
yeah, yeah thousand seconds crossed a thousand guys we did it
didn't think we'd get here but man
Thank you to those who believed in me and my failures
Oh, no you don't.. Oh, no you don't.. Oh, no you don't.. Oh, no you don't.. Oh, no you don't.. oh no you don't
okay all right
alright
alright boop no
All right we're back here okay so i think i'm not a hundred percent sure but i think the secret is right
Here yes oh i don't know her i went but i went away
Okay but that's okay everything's fine
ha
How much farther must I be from the end I don't imagine that this game would be as long as oh as
as the Bennett Foddy
THE Bennett Foddy
hup
Okay where am I going over there i'd like to think so
boink
Ha ha ha ha where is this where am I *Surprised oh*
wha-oh-ha-wha-what?-what?-huh-ya-YEAH YEAH YEAH
I DID IT! I WAS SO CLOSE
*crying while speaking* Buh Buh Fuck you *sobs*
UHHHHHH
*laughing while crying*
*painfull thumbs up* ((poor mark BUT HE'S A GOOD BOY))
*weekly* I did it
*crying* I did it I did it I'm so proud of myself
*more crying*
Ok *another painfull thumbs up*
All right that took way too longIi took way too much time at that
I spent like an hour of my life on that
I feel good I feel good for what I accomplished but I feel really bad
okay all right next up in the cavalcade of dicka tree is NEURAL BOTS
This actually won first place in the game jam
why didn't I do it first I don't know
because I didn't want to rage too hard and yet here we are
let's play oh cry-baby normal are you crazy speed run mode i don't know what
game is on line so others can see your name
I don't know can i just do normal first?
*voice in game* Oh, well I didn't expect anything more from you anyway
What??? *laugh*
Left click to- OH
((just read the screen))
oh no OH OH
oh ho ho
No, oh, no oh
no, this is how I control it oh this is the worst thing what is that that looks dangerous I don't like it
OH OK well that doesn't help me at all
*mocking* BoT tWo
*painful laugh* oh god
Oh, no all right I think I can control this
ohhhh shit well, fuck me then
i'm trying man look look I can only do so much with these control
okay why did that hit me? why did I die there?
I know why I died cuz that's just a pure lay's or ain't it
gimme the checkmark give it to me okay all right then ahh
I didn't know that was sweeps
oh FUCK
come on
OOOH ok oh AHH AHH
I was so close
Oh no All right here we go
Okay well that's fine I got the checkpoint and that's fine who could do this on one go through I can't even go two inches
they they ran out of text for for the amount of bots that i've destroyed oh
boy
That's you know you could also just say
christmas is gonna happen before i'm done but you know well let's go with the j bebs thing I
Did it I did it you suck i'm getting better at this ha unlike those other games oh?
oh, well shit alright well shit oh
no that's my ass that's my ass exploded okay alright I miss your narration man come on
dude I know me
Dude I don't know man I don't know man what do you want from me go sit on the toilet
Eat, some food whatever you're talking about you were just saying nonsensical dribble anyway so what does it matter
oh
that was it oh
I did it fuck you I got it yeah
All right let me just see what hardcore is like speedrun mode no check no
No, I forgot overall that's too fast that's not fair
are you out of your go shit fuck no it's like playing with inverted controls while also taking shrooms
I'm not doing it not after what i've been doing i'm not doing it no you know if you guys want to play that you
can i'm not in an emotionally ready mood to go through that bullshit I didn't think I was gonna go through all the
Bullshit before but i'm not ready alright I got another game for you so this one is called quit just as simple as that
just called-
get it okay this one's called quit as you might have noticed
This game is going to be a waste of your time great if you're smart you'll quit the game right now
well i'm not very smart as we have all determined what
Oh, I lose if I stray off the bat dumb enough to not do what you wanted to do without good reason coming over you
Know then again I didn't really understand that questioned it seemed like a loop-de-loop
Of a question and and my brain wasn't prepared for it so you know no, no it's just amazing oh no
is he gonna is it just it's just it's just amazed
The way out
at the end of the beginning or the beginning of the end what stop talking in circles
stop your philosophical circle-jerk I don't want it I don't want any of it I just want I just want you to
Inflict your pain upon me then i'll leave like that's the exchange that we have dear in control or are you winning
is your life real or just pretend again it's you soccer tease here? Can you shove a cock in it? I dont
want, to be a part of that I just want
Doesn't even matter how hard you try keep that in mind I designed this rhyme
To explain in due time that you trying way too hard
Shut the- Fuck up *Gigglyplier*
It's not, worth it i know it's not, worth it this is the same this the same
Is the same exact maze
The same exact maze it's the same
No, okay why do I slide down words that come on I hate it okay all right okay?
okay
No, okay no, okay no, how about how about we don't do this how about we don't okay
oh
time lord valuable thing watch it fly by as the pendulum swings
if they reverse the controls up is now down down is now up well i could still beat this you bullshit i've got enough training
And the inverted controls to be able to
control your bullshit okay it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine and
I mean i want to quit the game who you who you better believe me i want to quit the game we were off
To a bad start of this relationship before we even left the door there
To the end of the day the clock ticks life away oh, no the controls are reversed and it's spinning, oh
okay it's fine cuz I owe and it's spinning and it's drifting ah
this is horrible okay ignore everything iIsaid about this being fine this is actually horrible
something else I want - trust me I want to
believe you butter your bull
press escape to ski i'm not gonna shut up
we've made my suffering alone this is my special time and you're invading
You don't understand if you think this is easy if you're
Like dom enough to not do what you wanted to do without good reason
coming over you're just gonna repeat what you've said before because if you are I will throw my
Computer out of my window oh my god and dumb enough to not do what you wanted to do without good reason
coming over it's gonna leave that same phrases
yes, yes that beef that would equip meat is made up so put away your makeup I told you once I
won't tell you again it's a bad way
Huh!
understand that
Lyrics you're just saying song lyrics but I don't get it the controls are normalized now thank goodness but it's still spinny drifty
Still doing this no that's no that's right way maybe I don't even know anymore
life is valuable do you know my life I
Don't think we're talking about the same thing here oh, how could i forget the way out i've been doing it ecstasy
crossy and then up here you know
It's not gonna work that's how this works that's how this easy
nice and calm and when I do i'm taking your time right behind you back
You're talking to yourself at night and the message coming to your eyes says "leave it alone"
perhaps you should maybe I should
the controls are
The reverse sin I didn't even what
what kind of controls are these? what are the- what are- *Gibberish*
wait what doing it he just he's just crapping out on me I
guess we're done
I guess were done *Gigglypilier*
alright there you have it that's the end
Thank you everybody so much for watching if for some godforsaken
Reason you want to play these games for yourself i'll provide them in the description check it out there
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you (laughs) thought down the comments below
and as always! I will see you
In the next video.
Bu-bye!!
Make sure you subscribe to mark He is the best hit those notifications and leave a like for him!